stell dir vor wir könnten alles ganz
genau sehen jedes kaum jedes teil
wir könnten die muster dahinter erkennen
sind sie zufällig oder managen
zufällig bin ich die grundzüge der
geschichte sind oder es sich um einen
indischen mathematiker vor etwa 100
jahren training raser ramadan der zu den
zehn bedeutendsten mathematikern
sicherlich das 20 jahrhunderts gehört es
ist aber vor allem als reine unschöne
mathematik einfach sehr beeindruckend
was er geleistet hat ist es umso
beeindruckender
weil er in kolonialer rückständigkeit
und armut im damaligen indien frau wie
gesagt etwa 100 jahren aufgewachsen ist
denke ich und dann hat der briefe
geschrieben an die hervorragendsten
mathematiker und köpfe seiner zeit
insbesondere in england und darum
gebeten diese arbeit möbel gewürdigt
werden was ein einziger dann auch
wirklich getan hat nämlich geld hd in
cambridge der ihnen kommen ließ und
gefördert habe mir jegliche rat den sie
mir geben von höchstem wert sein
ihr ergebene es lama notieren
es ist ein film weniger über ergebnisse
der mathematik also es gibt keine
schautafeln in dem sinne keine
infografiken keine animation was es gibt
es einen blick darauf wie leute die
etwas sehr zurückgezogenes tun etwas
sehr stilles tun miteinander kooperieren
die beiden schauspieler die das spielen
nämlich dev patel als ramadan und der
grossartige jeremy irons als hd sorgen
erfüllen das in einer weise mit leben
und leidenschaften und zarten und
bitteren und großartigen momenten das
ist einfach nicht besonders
ein theaterstück ist in dem
diese gesichter so wirken als ob das
wirklich köpfe sind die was denken sie
die schauspielführung der figuren die
dialoge die art wie sozusagen teilweise
mit dem kleinsten lächeln oder mit der
körperlichen menschen also wie zum
beispiel sich zu recht in diesem zimmer
dass man ihn stellt wir mit diesem
papier kontakt aufnimmt dass sie da
hinlegen weil er halt vorher trägst
erklärte das sind momente die sozusagen
die wirklichkeit die materielle
wirklichkeit von geistiger arbeit in
einer weise treffen wie man sehr
seltenen film sich absolut sicher sein
dass jede form von dem sie träumen ganz
sogar falsch ist
nun dann können sie sich wieder unter
ihrem felsen im hintersten indien
verkriechen und wir können
ich würde den film vor allen dingen zwei
gruppen von leuten empfehlen leuten die
sich überhaupt nicht dafür interessieren
weil sie zumindest einen begriff davon
bekommen warum es leute gibt die sich
dafür interessieren und natürlich leute
die sich dafür interessieren dazwischen
ist auch noch viel platz aber wenn man
sich ganz einfach nur für filme
interessiert in denen sozusagen
leistungen erbracht werden vom
schauspielensemble manchmal ob diese
figur vergesse ich nie mehr
dann drückt sich allein schon wegen
scheinlich von film zu film immer immer
besser wird und allmählich ist es so
jetzt soll er mal aufhören weil sonst
versteht man es gar nicht mehr wie das
geht
es gibt weder beweise noch gesetze die
sich auf herzensangelegenheiten anwenden
lassen uns bleibt die unendlichkeit zu
erforschen
auf der suche nach höchster
vollkommenheit